black artists making history now from
the moguls and change makers
don't do something until you're inspired
to entertainers living their truth
we should center black lives in this
conversation
i'm alyssia johnson and joining me in a
discussion on the stars
setting the bar for excellence mtv news
anchor doma t pongo
hold up i'm building businesses y'all
gotta wait i love rereading
journalists and hosts of black girl
podcast gia peppers
tyler is opening up the dream in the
space to all of us
and from netflix's okay now listen
sylvia obell
it's so important for us to be the
authors of our own stories
i think it's only right for us to kick
things off with bad girl riri
robin rihanna fenty who went from
singing
panda replay in 2005 which was my jam
to being the world's richest female
musician
now gia this woman is an empire it's
music it's fashion it's beauty
how do you think rihanna has managed to
rise to this level of success
i think rihanna is the master of not
only the pivot but being
absolutely everything she wants to be
whenever she wants to be it
rihanna has changed the game literally
in beauty
and fashion and music she gave us eight
studio albums over a decade then she
gave us
lbmh being the first black woman to have
a fashion house with them with fenty
luxury line
now fenty beauty is changing the game
and literally fanty makeup
made other makeup brands make other
shades for black women and women of
color all over the place so
for me rihanna understands that when she
wants to show up she's going to show up
in so much excellence that everyone else
has to see her
as a formidable businesswoman a star
whatever she wants to be and you always
want to be her friend
so like she's just perfect part of the
key to rihanna's magic
is that she always keeps her ear to the
street like she knows what her fans want
and need from her she knows what black
women
are lacking in the marketplace and like
i literally i'm wearing savage
fenty all right now in this one setting
so it's like she really
really gets the need for what we're
looking for for sure
even though she has her finger on like
the pulse of what her audience wants she
doesn't let them lead her too far she
remains
singularly focused while fans are
begging her for an album she's like
hold up i'm building businesses y'all
gotta wait i love re-reading
we can't talk about moguls without
mentioning tyler perry
he knows how to listen to his base he's
been able to tap into his market
and he doesn't forget where he came from
and that allows him to create the next
generation of leaders
even with the stage and the studio that
he's open so i think uh you know a lot
of folks who criticize him
have to look at the larger picture and
everything he's doing in totality
because it really is a business case
study
i also think we don't say enough how
tyler perry really stood in the gap
while hollywood was still catching up
when we think of the roles he gave to
taraji kimberly elise gabriel union
when they weren't able to get work that
helped them catapult themselves
back into mainstream that's an important
thing that tyler has done
we also wouldn't have black panther
without his studio
and a lot of other shows we love so
those are very important
he built a table he understood his power
his path and his purpose and he shares
it and gives it back to hollywood tyler
is opening up the dream in the space to
all of us
and shoot i'm trying to film something
tyler let me know i'm gonna be there
look we have to move on though
to some black entertainers and creators
who are boldly living in their truth
and at the same time inspiring others to
do the same
when i think of that i think of janet
mock she directs she produces and writes
for the fx series pose
and she made history in 2019 when
she landed an overall deal with netflix
sylvia can you talk about the
significance of her getting a deal like
this
oh you need my good co-worker
that's what i do anytime somebody gets a
job at netflix i'm like oh hey
but no i didn't love made history she
literally made history
she's the first black trans woman to
have an overall deal with any major
studio
and that is a testament to her talent
and her
result i mean her hustle because
honestly she was breaking barriers with
pose
before it was popular before it was
trendy and i really think we need to
give janet her
just due for that and i'm very excited
to see
what other shows she creates because i
think even in this quarantine with the
absence of pose
we're realizing how big of a gap there
is for queer storylines on television
and i'm really excited to see janet fill
that through her netflix deal but also
hopefully it opened the door for more
trans
and queer voices and writers and
entertainers to do the same
since we're talking about polls we have
to talk about billy porter
he is a force on and off the red carpet
by the way
but he made history for his emmy win for
the fx series
in 2019. domiti what do you think are
some of the necessary conversations
he sparked just by showing up as himself
in the industry
well he always sparks a conversation
with what he has on so his fashion makes
a statement before he enters the room
but what i love about billy porter is
that in this moment
he's found a way to remind us that he is
more than just those shows more than
just
a singer more than just an actor more
than just a playwright i mean
this man has done so much for the
industry and you're starting to see the
influence of these lgbtq creators
not only in shows like pose or drag race
or even our own logo live
but when you see shows like pea valley
that have these
other story lines that offshoot into
very important issues within that
community and i think that's thanks to
folks like janet mott
and billy porter yeah for sure and he's
also been vocal about
his experience with homophobia in the
black community
and he hasn't shied away from hauling
the black community out
about that but gia i want to move on to
someone that you're super passionate
about
lina waith in 2017 lena made history
when she won an emmy
for writing a masters of none episode
about her coming out experience
in what ways do you think lena is
changing the game gia
there are so many ways and i think the
most the most
i think controversial way she changed
the game is when she put out queen and
slim she didn't take any notes from any
studios right she put it out with her
vision in mind
and i think what we saw was someone that
is true to the vision and also a
product of what hard work really looks
like she worked her way up
in every single opportunity and took
over and decided to show up and show out
not only as a queer woman but as a woman
who's of color she she thinks about
black women in
all over the spectrum and we see it in
her shows from the shy to 20s on bet
which is literally
about her story and her coming of age in
l.a as a hollywood
writer and then director producer
creative right and so
the reason why i'm so passionate about
her is because she actually
literally continues to look back and
opens the door i could
email her and she will respond and i'm
like you're leaning away
like that's really crazy finally i want
to talk about
black artists speaking truth to power in
2018 kendrick lamar became the first
rapper in history
to win a pulitzer prize for his album
damn
which examines social issues and the
black experience in america today
donald t what do you think this win did
for hip-hop
first of all it puts hip-hop in the
conversation with
previous pulitzer prize winners like
gwendolyn brooks alex haley who wrote
roots and the autobiography of malcolm x
and it really reminds people what hip
hop is at his core it's prose it's
literary consciousness it's the voice of
the unheard it literally means rap
literally stands for rhythm
and poetry and why i'm so excited about
it is i actually think the stronger
album was the pimple butterfly when it
came out before dan
and so the power in it is that now we go
back to his archives wearing that album
he pays homage to tupac so now he's
gonna lead people down the rabbit hole
of
looking at hip-hop looking at rap within
the
the annals of history as something
that's akin to what langston wrote
what maya wrote i mean kendrick tupac
these writers are right on par with them
and i think that
an honor like this cements that that's
why that's why i'm so excited about it
i mean even last thing on that even with
the protest songs the songs that became
the voice of the movement like all right
if you were out in the the streets
covering these protests or marching
the energy was palpable when these songs
were saying when protesters would
shout out these lyrics back when they
used to sing change is going to come and
we shall overcome
he became those new negro spirituals and
so this is it's a defending honor for
sure
rappers are storytellers and it's the
yeast critiques belong
of america belong up in the ranks of
academia
just like anybody else's all right well
let's move on to ava duvernay
her work has made her the highest
grossing black female director
in american box office history sylvia
what impact has her filming had on
educating people
on systemic racism and police brutality
ava really puts the heart into these
stories and into these
narratives that we often read about
instead of black men being a statistic
we get to see when they see us
and really see them that's why i love
the title of that even with queen sugar
and her other and um the 13th
documentary she's putting names faces
and families and
heart and soul into this issue with
america that makes it so hard to ignore
and it's very like i there's a
difference between reading about the
central park five
and watching each boy get ripped apart
at the precinct
the way you do i was a mess by part five
and i think that's why it's so important
for us
to be the authors of our own stories
because we
will put the heart into it because it
was our experience and ava really shows
the difference there last but not least
jordan peele
he made he made history in 2018 by
becoming the first black writer
to win best original screenplay at the
oscars for get out
gia tell us about your initial reaction
when you first saw the film
and what did you think the public was
going to think about it
i was scared to go back to the suburbs
where my parents lived i'm not gonna
hold you i was like you know
just in case i make the wrong left turn
i am a little afraid but no i think what
jordan peele
brings to horror which we're seeing like
we saw how well
get out did and then us did now we're
seeing candyman come back and we're
seeing all these new movies
that feature the black millennial
version of horror right which i think is
so inspiring but
um you know get out was that first time
where we saw something that is really
not
that out of scope like it wasn't a
a fantastical movie that could really be
happening you can literally drug people
and hypnotize them and make them crazy
you know what i'm saying
i think that's why jordan is so good at
bringing those stories to life daniel
kaluuya's skin
was glowing in that yeah
in the same way that lena wave had had
dark skin glowing and queen and slim
like uh gia pepper so eloquently pointed
out so
not only the content but how we shot the
cinematography
and how black directors are able to look
at melanated people and make us pop on
camera the way we should in ways that
other directors don't always do yeah
well speaking of skin glowing i must say
we all look good with this melanin
popping on the screen right now
so thank you this is so fun
this was a great conversation and we're
going to keep this conversation going
about artists speaking truth to power
our very own tondo glomo has more on the
makers
behind the movements the celebrities who
are using their platforms to take a
[Music]
stand